hi everyone
i'm maurice samuels the director of the
yale program for the study of
anti-semitism
and along with my colleague carolyn dean
we want to welcome you here today it's
an especially
excuse me great honor to introduce
today's speaker
philip nord he's the rosengarten
professor of modern and contemporary
history at princeton
where he's taught since 1981. one of the
leading historians of late 19th and 20th
century france
excuse me he's devoted his career to
exploring the working of
ideologies like anti-semitism and
republicanism
and how they shape cultural forms excuse
me
his books include paris shopkeepers and
the politics of resentment
1986 the republican moment struggles for
democracy
in 19th century france 1995
impressionists and politics art and
democracy in the 19th century
2000 france's new deal from the 30s to
the post-war era
2010 and his new book which we'll be
talking about
today after the deportation memory
battles
in post-war france which was just
published by cambridge university press
and is the subject of a round table on h
diplo that carolyn
edited and i'll just say that this book
is stunning
in both its breadth and its depth as i
said in my review for that round table
it's going to be the definitive history
of the way that world war ii
was remembered in france phil nord is a
guggenheim fellow
a former director of the shelby column
davis center for historical studies at
princeton
and the recipient of many awards and
honors he also happens to be
a fellow chicagoan so now let me just
say
a word about how things will work today
first phil will present the book then
carolyn
is going to say a few words about it
then we'll open it up to your questions
and we'll finish promptly at 6 pm
so please submit your questions using
the q a
function at the bottom of your screen
and i will ask them
to fill please don't raise your hand
since we won't see you
you're welcome to start submitting
questions at any time
including during the lecture itself and
now
i will hand it over to professor philip
nord
thank you maury um so uh greetings to
the audience whom i
can't see but i uh i'm hopeful if not
confident that you're uh that you're out
there
uh let me express also uh with some uh
begin by expressing some words of thanks
uh to maury samuels and carolyn dean for
organizing this event
uh and also uh a word also uh
for alice kaplan uh who was supposed to
participate
but has been ill and so i'd like to wish
her uh wish her well
so let me begin with a few introductory
uh
remarks before we turn to uh the
discussion
uh about 160 000 french people uh were
deported from france
during world war ii uh to nazi camps in
central
uh in eastern europe 76 000
of these deportees for jews uh
and for jews deportation and effect
meant a sentence of death
very few returned a couple thousand a
little bit more
but almost everybody who was deported
was murdered
uh for the others uh
many of these were raising stone or
resistance fighters
uh and uh their chances of dying were
high as well
uh a little under 50 percent
so their two very different experiences
is these mortality rates
a test uh of what the deportation
experience was like and yet in french
uh both experiences are subsumed under a
common term
la de potassio the deportation
immediately at the end of the war
stories started to be told
about this about this experience they
were told in a variety of
a variety of formats through a variety
of means and vehicles
uh books poetry movies
artwork monuments uh memorials of all
kinds
this right from the right from the very
start
and the people who told these stories
fashioned them
um came from a variety of backgrounds
some were survivors
some were relatives of survivors some
were artists who
thought the experience burdened urgent
enough uh
that they felt they had to deal with it
in one way uh or another night i
discussed a number of these in my books
and i'll
uh cite you uh a list it's longer than
that but of some of the principal ones
anton pablo picasso allah renee
john kerou david rousseau edgar mohan
jorge centrum edmond ellie wiesel andre
schwartzbart
claude logsman and others uh as well
whom i'll mention uh in my remarks
uh uh as we go uh as we go along
so uh many media uh many people
it's an enormous outpouring uh i wind
down my analysis of this corpus of work
sometime in the mid 1990s but it
continues
on down to the present days and i'm
still
i'm still reading it and i suspect i
will be reading it
for many years to come these stories are
patterned uh
by political and religious uh religious
commitments
uh the communists were among the first
uh to get into the story
uh story telling practice or game
i don't want to use that word uh get
into the practice of storytelling
uh told a story of anti-fascist of
anti-fascist struggle the non-communists
left
also entered the fray not long
thereafter and for them the
concentrationary
form uh was not the epinaj
of uh of uh of the fascist world alone
uh but of uh of totalitarians and
generals
stalinists as well as hitler had uh
had concentration uh concentration camps
uh for others uh the concentration
reform was something
uh that was imminent uh in modern life
uh itself and you found it everywhere uh
not just
in uh in hitler's germany uh or in
stalin's uh stalin's
soviet union uh but you found that even
uh in france itself
uh france maintaining uh internment at
concentration camps uh during the
algerian uh
the algerian war
the gauls also had a word to say uh
about
about camps and deportation but they saw
it through the lens
uh of an ongoing struggle against
hereditary full
germany and discussed this experience in
the framework of
what they call the 30 years war
now as for religious commitments roman
catholic
deportees talked about their experience
as a fight of the spirit against the
nazi
neo-paganism and jews too had something
to say
about the deportation experience really
right from the uh
right from the very very beginning uh it
was seen in a variety of lights in these
first post-war decades
uh as part of a a millennial long
experience of persecution that dated
back to biblical times and from this
perspective
uh those who were murdered in the
deportation
murdered in the camps had died as
martyrs
in sanctification of the name kidus
hashem
but others stressed uh jewish resistance
uh in the face of nazi persecution uh
citing the case of the warsaw ghetto
uprising
uh but not just that uh there were also
sunder commando revolts
uh in various death camps at helmno
sobibor and treblinka
and these two were celebrated and these
jewish dead
were understood to be not just martyrs
but also also heroes
so there is an ebb and flow to the
to the stories told about the
deportation a variety of themes uh
and narratives that inter interweaving
try to make
four points about these uh about this
ebb and flow
one is it's inflected by events the
major events
of the euro the cold war of course the
algerian war which i've already uh
already mentioned uh but also the war of
uh of 1967 the arab israeli war with the
negativist crisis of the 1980s
and 1990s uh and i should add as well
de gaulle's return to power in 19 in
1958
but jews were always a part of the story
uh it used to be receive wisdom that
there was a long silence
uh and of course in many homes and many
families uh
that's true but i'm talking about a
public silence uh
it used to be thought that there was a
public science in the silence and the
jewish experience and jewish suffering
was not not discussed and i i try to
push back against this a little bit
uh acknowledging that in the first war
decades with it while there was a jewish
voice
there were many many other voices that
were much louder
and occupied more space in the public in
the public domain
all these voices not quite a cacaofani
but sometimes they contended with each
other competed with each other
and fought against each other and the
communist goalless struggle over
deportation memory is perhaps
the most the most well-known uh and
that's why i put memory battles
in the title of my book because uh while
there's cooperation
uh there is also uh there is also
contention
now the jewish voice would grow stronger
in the 1970s uh
in 1980s and eventually become
by the 1990s the dominant
the dominant one uh and as a result
historians talk about a reversal
a reversal of memory and as i see it
it's not just that the jewish voice
becomes dominant
but also the tonality of the jewish
story itself
begins to change with the focus less
on heroism and on modernism and more
on the experience on the experience of
lost
the emphasis is no longer on sacrifice
more on loss and sometimes also
on victimization all this
of course begs the question as to why
such a reversal of memories
took place the answer to this
and others have addressed it the
question uh
my answer is a little a little different
often the practice is to emphasize
um very particular does the eichmann
trial
of 19 of 1961 uh which is supposed to
turn the light on in public
consciousness uh or
the arab-israeli war of 1867 and uh 1967
forgive me
uh and i do treat these events but i
interpret them less as
turning points than as accelerators
pushing a process forward
that had its origins uh in elsewhere
uh and other kinds of uh and other kinds
of
with other kinds of explanations and i
insist uh on two vectors of change in
particular
uh the first once again not unique to me
but i
put a lot of weight on it as a catholic
jewish
dialogue christian jewish dialogue
catholic
in in in particular
so catholics play a prominent role in my
story
uh of two kinds one is uh brokers or
intermediaries as passer who helped
bring the jewish story uh to public
attention
and here i would cite the case of
jacques marita who's a very good friend
of
mark chagalls collected some of
chagall's
work or fros moriak
who provided the introduction to ellie
wiesel's la nui
uh when it was published in french in
1958
and also a lesser-known figure a man
named paul flammo who was the editor
at la soy but la soy was the publishing
house
that first published andrei
schwarzenbach
de justin the last of the just in 1959
which was a pre-gall court winning a
very prestigious prize
flammable published ellie wiesel after
la lui
and he was also the publisher of some of
saul friedlander's
first works and some of you in the
audience will know
saul friedlander's spectacular work uh
on the hall across the recent
valley study
but it wasn't all uh about dialogue
there was also a lot of connection
between christians and jews between
catholics and jews over the memory and
this
too roiled uh that the public
the public domain uh and this connection
i would cite
three things first of all the work of
julie zach
some of you may know it wrote a
groundbreaking
and hefty text which was published in
the late 40s
jesus israel and in it he excoriates the
church
for what he calls the teaching of
contempt the teaching of anti-semitism
across millennia a teaching that in
isaac's
izak's uh polemic greased the wheels
that led train loads of jews
to auschwitz
not just izak there's also the finale
affair
uh which erupted uh in public life in
1952 and 1953. i
i don't want to rehearse it in detail
but uh two
uh two jewish boys have been placed uh
for safe keeping during the war by their
parents
uh with a catholic religious order the
parents were deported
uh and uh and murdered uh
the children survived looked after by
this religious order who farmed them out
to a nurse
and after the war an ant came looking
for them
uh and the caretaker had the children
baptized and the church did not want to
let go of the children in effect
kidnapping them and there was a major
major
public uproar that was not just national
but international
at the same time very contentious
in the end the boys were released uh to
their aunt and the family
uh the remnants of the finale family
uh moved to israel uh i treat this
as a scene setter uh for uh the catholic
church's
vatican ii reflections on its teaching
on the jews and at vatican ii
uh a papal uh a declaration
uh follows uh called nostra itati
uh in our times uh which represents
a beginning uh of rethinking church
doctrine
not jewish life but the catholic jewish
dialogue plays a major role in my
in my discussion uh and so too does 1968
now i understand 1968 not just the
events of bay
of that year in france but as a longer
phenomenon which historians call the
long 68 begins
somewhere in the mid-1960s and stretches
on into the
at the beginning of the meter presidency
in the early uh early 1980s
and to me 68 understood in this way is
meaningful in my story in three ways
first of all a number of the principles
were 68ers uh marcelo fools uh was
active in a
strike at the public uh uh at public
television in 1968 and
some of you will know who marcelo fools
was uh
made a couple of uh quite spectacular
movies uh
having to do with the wartime experience
the sorrow and the pity the chagrin
pta which he completed in 69 and
and showed not on tv but in movie
theaters in 1971
later in 1976 another movie called the
movement uh the
memory of uh memory of justice which
deals not just with
the war but also with france's algerian
war and with the american war in vietnam
pushing them all together and inviting
people to reflect about
uh the connections between these kinds
of experiences
uh or uh i could mention biataclarsfeld
once again you'll uh some of you will
know who the klarsfelds were
biata and she was involved in strikes in
1968
in uh in france so there were 68ers
involved in the
uh in the story and as oh fool's movies
uh demonstrate what they were doing with
their
artwork was in part how should i put it
uh busting uh myths about uh
about world war ii particularly
galleston and communist ones
uh and in effect uh uh received wisdom
on what the war had been
all about in effect clearing the memory
decks so that
other kinds of stories not communists
not comment
not gauls but other kinds of stories
jewish in particular
could surge uh into the public into the
public consciousness
and a third way in which 68 uh
played a uh played a role has to do with
techniques
uh and here biataclars felt this a good
case in point biata and serge
both who did scholarly work
uh but also who were past masters
at publicizing events orchestrating
courtroom dramas taking part in
demonstrations
sit-ins uh all to force
uh uh on the public a consciousness of
what had happened to the jews
during the second during the second
world war now the last
substantive chapter of my book uh deals
with quote
last month's show on uh and i wind up
there for a variety of reasons
uh i suppose uh one of them is that it's
a monumental
work uh and monuments figure very
prominently
uh in most of the chapters of of my book
uh there is a communist corner at
paralyzed cemetery in northeastern
paris where there is a whole host of
concentration camp
memorials uh i should also mention
the memorial o martial
on the il some of you will have visited
it's located just behind
notre dame notre dame maybe not easy of
access
uh these days um there is
a concentration camp immoral in france
itself
at strathoff
the memorial showa as it's now known
in the marie which is a jewish memorial
when it was first opened in 1956
uh it was known by another name as the
tombow du materia
canoes the tomb of the unknown jewish
martyr changed his name to the memorial
the
unknown jewish martyr today the memorial
de la shoah
so uh i discussed memorials throughout
monuments throughout
uh and last month's work is is
monumental at overnight
over nine hours in length also
it gives a new name uh to the experience
of
jewish deportation um in france the
holocaust is
used but not as currently as the word
showa it's a strange word from from the
hebrew
not well known but it catches something
something
and this is the third reason why i end
up of the singularity and unprecedented
nature of the of the holocaust
unprecedented in its scales and its
means uh and in its means
of execution
and last month's movie exemplifies as
well
this new understanding of what the showa
was
not a story of heroism or even of
martyrs but a story of
uh unredeemed uh of unredeemed loss and
in this connection the figures
uh in the movie who stand out for me and
i suspect for
others as well are the zonder commandos
uh
those uh who were charged with disposing
of the body
bodies of the murder uh people like
philippe mueller
uh and um
and abraham bamba who both figure uh
prominently
as interviewees in lanzmann's movie and
they were cylinder commandos who had
literally entered into the gas chambers
and come out again alive and could tell
about uh
as much as any living human being could
about what that experience was and then
of course the figure of simon schrevnick
uh who was his under commandoed helm
note charged with burning bodies
and it's with him uh that landscape
opens the movie
uh and closes and closes i conclude
uh i have a conclusion epilogue on a
conclusion
uh with some reflections about uh why
uh this outpouring uh and
an outpouring so inventive in its nature
uh uh happened in france why there uh
and not say uh in israel or the united
states
um not that it was ignored in israel the
united states but it is
uh unusually creative from the french
and the french context and i i propose
three kinds of explanations for that
first one
is if i were to hesitate to use is
demographic but it's a way of saying
uh that one there were a lot of jews in
france
uh after the war the jewish community is
about a quarter of a million
strong uh yes 70 70 i think 78
79 000 jews total were murdered of the
french jewish community but three
quarters of the community survived
uh in hiding or in exile and then they
returned after the war
so there was a jewish population that
had an experience of persecution
in france itself numerous
and willing to speak in addition to that
there were all the razi stone deportees
who came back
tens of thousands of them uh with
stories of their own to tell so there
was
a a community varied in nature
uh that had an interest in wanting to
talk about
the deportation experience
not just that uh there are political
reasons
why this mattered so much in france
france had suffered defeat in 1940 in
occupation uh
thereafter uh experiences of humiliation
and there were crazy stunts but also
deportees
whose sacrifice could be understood as
something redemptive so that the story
of the war was not just a story of
humiliation defeat uh but a horror
story of uh of resistance uh and
uh uh and uh redemptive sacrifice at the
same time
and the question is who would own this
particular memory uh
it came freighted with a lot of moral
authority and and many many currents of
opinion
uh wanted to control it uh and there was
contention
over that control and last of all
and my interlocutors are all experts on
this
uh greater experts than than i am and it
would be true if we added
alice kaplan into the group uh the
postwar decades in france there are
periods of exceptional
uh exceptional creativity and
deportation literature intersects uh
with these currents of creativity
with uh surrealism and existentialism
uh with modernist with modernist uh
architecture
with new wave cinema uh with the new
novel
uh with julie paul which is the ouvra
uh de lite potassiul uh
i don't know how to translate that but
in any case it's a literary movement
that george perek belonged to
and he writes about the deportation uh
um in w souvenir dolph false
and when it comes to movies uh
the intersection between uh cutting-edge
cinema and the deportation is complete
and i just mentioned once again uh renee
and kehoel's
movie night and fog but not just
uh not just that marcelo fools sauron
opinions lanzmann's showa
and there are more uh edgar mohammad
jaroush
uh chronique which is 1961 uh
and a lesser known movie called the
toned ghetto
from 1961 also these are all
very creative imaginative imaginative
works so it's my hope uh that people who
read the book even if they don't agree
with anything i have to say will at
least
find it worthwhile to visit or
revisit the works that i discuss
in the book the monuments the artwork
the novels because it is a
creative corpus and quite wonderful
that deserves uh the whitest possible
public
thank you very much thank you uh
phil for that uh really great summary of
the book so now
we'll have a few words from carolyn and
then we will open it up to questions so
everyone in the audience please start um
sending questions using the q a function
at the bottom
of your screen welcome everyone welcome
to
professor philip nord uh thank you maury
uh i i just wanted to take a few minutes
to clarify the importance of
philip north's new book partly because
as he
as he says he pushed back a little bit
on a certain assumption about the fact
that jews
in france during the immediate post-war
period until 1968 were
silent now he doesn't just push back on
this idea a little bit he actually
draws our understanding of deportation
in france in fact
this book is and i say this with no
exaggeration
the most important discussion and
history
of deportation from vichy france of jews
and communist political dissidents
in the of the past 30 years the the
first important discussion which really
set the stage was book which was called
the vichy syndrome
which uh suggested that there was this
silence and it had been
uh and noise though there was discussion
among jews
uh noise the the noise began only about
the jewish deportation and specificity
only in 1968.
before i sort of discuss this say this
just a little more
in more detail in a minute i just want
to know for the audience those of you
who may or
may not know this and perhaps phil would
like to comment on this
after uh in the question the q and a
session
that the majority of jews deport from
france during this period were in fact
foreign jews
who had fled nazis or and austria
since hitler took power in 1938 i mean
1933 excuse me
um and of course annexed austria in 1938
and and they were also those jews who
who had been naturalized french
especially
since 1927 was a very important
naturalization law
and many jews from eastern europe who
had
lived in france had been naturalized and
the french government under the vichy
regime undertook a denaturalization
process
of many of these jews not all of them
who were stripped of their citizenship
and that men were allowed to be in turn
by definition they were all enemies
of the state uh and they were interned
in in term in france
so i i thought that was just an
interesting
uh a fact that that would be important
to mention because the majority of
french jews not all of them of course
did survive uh and that is a question
that has raised
a lot of that has
provoked a lot of discussion and debate
and i
feel wanted to speak to that just
because it's an interesting fact about
france
now let me just reiterate some things
phil
said very quickly after 1945 the french
imagined deportee
as anti-fascist patriotic victims of the
nazi regime
that were usually are usually cited for
this period
and communist accounts of french heroic
martyrdom
focused on resistance fighters collected
jewish suffering
that is the usual narrative about this
period
it goes on to say immediately after the
war the french rarely made distinctions
between death camps and concentration
camps
or imagine them to be different for nazi
torture and persecution some people died
in death camps and some
in concentration camps jews as as
phil has noted were supposedly silent
meaning that they spoke to each other
experiences but their voices were
otherwise inaudible
so it was only these this narrative goes
after 1968
and the student rebellion when this
younger generation
questioned french complicity and
also criticized french colonialism and
these
devils uh uh researchers have have
argued
unearthed long repressed memories about
jewish persecution
and the vichy regime vetted until then
been buried
now the importance of phil's book it's
really shattered
really uh paradigm shattering uh um
this or my characterization of it and
many others as paradigm shattering
uh is because it tells an entirely
different story
that is not just pushing back a little
bit it is
other historians of course have
suggested the jewish voices have not
been entirely silent
but this book makes a much more
ambitious claim
that jews were far more central to the
postwar discussions than
than has been imagined and in arenas
some of the ones that phil mentioned
camp and war memorials
novels films catholic jewish dialogue
surprisingly
that we had not thought to explore
previously now he's discussed some of
this for
us today and given us much for thought
so i hope we can follow up
with uh and ask him more about this
important book
uh in the time remaining
thank you phil thank you great phil so i
don't know if you had something if you
wanted to react uh before we dive
i wanted to react to carolyn or adnan
yeah so just a few quick reactions i
i want to give the audience a chance to
uh
to jump in and carolyn invited me to say
something about
why france has such a substantial jewish
community
after after the war it's now
those of you who follow closely the new
york review books can see the uh
see the back and forth between robert
paxton and jackson milan
over justice justice issue um
many jews survive uh in in france and
it's foreign jews in particular who
deported but still
a large number of foreign jews
who've taken refuge in france in the
interwar decades they too
survive as well and in fact it's they
even more than the native uh native born
who will be active
uh in the santa du du du du months
which is one of the first organizations
that that pushes
jewish memory in the 1950s uh when there
was supposedly
uh supposedly silent uh the reasons
for jewish survival some of it has to do
with um
uh with geography uh there are mountains
uh it helps to have mountains uh the
alps
uh it helps to have remote countryside
as well so
which is why uh jews uh survival is much
less than
small countries like belgium or uh or
the netherlands uh
for that matter it also makes a
difference how hard the nazis tried
and whether they had the forces on hand
uh to execute their policy uh
and in the east they tried hard and they
had
uh the vermont to help out and this does
not come to pass in france to the same
way and so the level of murderousness
is not the same but i don't want to gain
say
uh what uh what semelon the argument
that he makes which is
that there were many people uh to help
jews jews themselves
uh in particular native born who had
resources and
language skills and could could protect
their countrymen
fellow jews but also
non-jewish non-jewish french people
uh peasants in particular who welcome
hid jews in their in their homes
uh but also religious institutions like
uh
protestant churches and some of you will
have heard of chambos
which is a protestant town uh which was
a
in effect a village refuge a place where
jews could go hide in fairly
significant numbers but the catholic
church as well
uh organized networks of networks
of rescue and if i mentioned saul
friedlander and he was protected
uh and all funkashay is called a hidden
child uh
in a uh in a catholic uh in a catholic
school and there are many other
instances of that i could go on but i
probably
i probably shouldn't uh yeah maybe i
undersold my book carolyn a little bit
okay i i appreciate your uh you're doing
uh doing that um and then
last of all there is the issue of
repressed memory and that's a tricky one
uh and i'm not sure that i negotiated it
uh
once again false modesty on my part
i negotiated it fully successfully uh
because there is the puzzle that if
there's a lot going
on uh why do people talk about repressed
memory
um and with conviction uh and i guess
i'd say a number of things to that one
is that when it comes to
internal life of families and
individuals uh
there's plenty of repressed memory uh
and so i
it's just in the public domain where
there are narratives uh
being being enunciated
that's where there's not the not the
silence and maybe these public stories
aren't satisfying
uh to individual people and they don't
see themselves in these public stories
in one
uh one way or another but also i try to
suggest that
that some of the uh earlier stories
emphasize religion
heroism martyrdom and that for younger
people
they're not interested in this kind of
thing these are not stories that
resonate with them
uh in any uh in any particular
uh particular way and in addition with
france in the mid 1960s
de gaulle is back in power and he is
putting the full weight of the state
behind a certain kind of memory politics
and for people who grow up
in the midst of that in the 60s it might
seem
as though nothing else existed but the
gala story
and maybe some communist story too if
you grew up in a leftist
in a leftist household and so at that
conjuncture that in that world it might
have seemed that there was silence
uh because other stories were being
blared so
loudly in nature and then last of all
the return of the repressed uh
paradigm is a is a is one that begins to
circulate in the 60s and 70s
and it's one that's embraced by young
people that's why we didn't know about
it
uh it was repression uh this is how uh
psyche works is how national psyches
were at the same
uh at the same time and so that's the
kind of explanation
explanatory framework that i i explore
okay so uh the the q a is blowing up
uh as they say so we have a lot of
questions
um so one one question uh from an
audience member is whether
um it just takes time
for um you know for not
for for um emotions to to pass
to allow for a more objective
non-apologetic writing so
it does that do you discuss that aspect
of things like maybe people
you know it's not just politics and
changing
politics but also just the fact that um
people
you know couldn't talk it took them a
while to be able to
talk after them yes and and there's
truth in that
uh i think immediately uh
both wiesel uh sketched
uh pieces of what would become la louis
early and then put it aside and jorge
sun prune
did the same thing and charlotte del
beau did the same thing
so there absolutely is truth to that uh
the only thing i would say is uh while
that's also true
right away after the war ends uh
deportees begin to appear uh
in their camp stripes in fact at public
events
uh and so uh
there was a mayday in 1945 uh communist
deportees are there
they parade in their uh in their stripes
uh
down the chaucer in effect uh
and the communists uh before the 1940s
are out are beginning to build memorials
in paralyzed
cemetery which are gathering places
so it may be hard for some people to
talk about
individually uh but when it comes to
collective
uh memory actions uh of the kind the
communists undertook and then de gaulle
pushes back right away
he retires from public life in 1946 and
goes quiet for a little period
but then people want to push back
against the comics you don't own the
deportation story
there are other stories that are told
here too and of course
there are those like isaac schneerson
who's the man behind the saint aj say
this
and he's his view is you know i do not
want the people who were murdered to die
without recognition of some kind or
another and i am going to see that a
monument is built to them
and he starts this he starts during the
war
in effect and he's a very determined uh
determined figure
uh and the memorial de la shawwa the
first stone is laid in 1953
uh and the building is completed in 1956
a very very early
uh memorialization uh but so yes it does
require i
i do want to acknowledge that um
particularly where individual memory
is concerned uh and some of the people i
talk about
have that kind of delay but in other
instances
there is no delay at all and they begin
laying down their markers
literally and fighting uh
over uh over this um and right from 44
45.
so i'm going to pick up i'm going to uh
jump to a question
um because you mentioned the um
the memorial on the il de la cite
and someone asked a question about that
and about the controversy
about whether it sufficiently focuses on
the jewishness
of victims um so could you say a little
bit more
about that monument and the story of
your time
uh so it's a quite wonderful monument
uh insufficient mention of the jews
there is none
okay uh i mean it is it is alighted
completely uh but it's also worth
noting who who got the monument built uh
and it's
uh three people in particular father
michelle rickey who's a jesuit father
and deportee was deported
to dachau for resistance activities in
the final semite but
that's may not be relevant men named
paul rodriguez
also a practicing uh roman catholic and
edmond michele
also a practicing roman catholic and the
architect that they got on board to
launch this
uh was a among other things
he was a modernist architect but also a
church architect
so that i treat this uh this monument is
having
a religious inspiration behind it behind
it initially
and as they tried to get the okay
to build this moment from various public
authorities the public authorities tell
them
this is okay but it should be to the
deportation in general
and not single anybody out so
no class no politics
no race no religion that's what they're
told
to do and so they try to do a big tent
memorial with a spiritual quality to it
and i think in its minimalism it has a
certain kind of spirituality
uh janet flanner who was the new
yorker's
woman in paris uh described it as like a
wayside
shrine
and it cites texts that
cover the full range uh there there are
written texts that are in the crypt of
the
uh of this memorial uh the full range of
um
resistance experience from father major
all the way to jean-paul sartre and
louis yargo i think also who's a
communist is also there
and it takes to build the concrete
it takes rock from all the mountain
ranges of france
and so it's meant to be this kind of
encompassing
non-denominational but spiritual
monument
uh and the deal is no the jews get no
mention
at all in this particular story although
as i said
father ricky himself is not an
anti-semite but on the contrary
took risks to save jews during during
the war and was deported
um right yeah such a that's such an
interesting
monument and you know we could talk more
about its placement but i want to go to
some of the other
um questions so one from uh someone who
i'm sure you know susan suleiman
who writes that um some historians and
other scholars would choose the
barbie the klaus barbie trial which
occurred a couple of years
after lonzoa as the culminating moment
of the story you're trying to tell the
memory of the deportation
especially since it led to a whole slew
of new memoirs by jewish deportees
as well as members of the resistance so
could you say a little bit more
about how you decided to to kind of end
your story
yeah it's interesting i you know i
how should i put it um i i don't say i
downplay the trials
uh there's a whole slew of them uh that
take place and they begin
in in cologne uh of uh of uh
nazi officials who had been part of the
uh
part of the police apparatus and
occupied occupied france
and then the series of uh of french
uh in fact that that was the interest
for me is is that
is the french people who participated in
the uh deportation
experience that like paul uh paul tuvier
or papo
uh maurice papa uh for that uh for that
matter
uh and the way in which this obliged the
french not just to think the germans did
bad things to us
which is easy uh and which they know but
that
we did bad things ourselves uh
it was the sheep that participated uh
that participated in this
and part of the interest for me in that
is that it then
draws attention not just to german
spaces but to spaces in france
uh of jewish suffering uh and that means
uh
places like draw seed the transit camp
in uh paris suburbs
uh or izure a children's home uh
uh not far from uh the uh the french
alps
uh where uh from which jewish children
were deported
because of barbie uh who was the
leon gestapo gestapo chief but so
barbie does figure and he figures in a
couple of ways in the story
uh one because the clars felds go after
him
uh and they track him down to bolivia
and make a fuss over a fuss over him
uh and bring him to the public attention
also barbie because of the easier story
which is one that's particularly
touching because it involves jewish
children
who who were murdered uh and so
it's part of the story um i i do end
with lancemont in part because of the
narrative power uh of the uh of this
particular uh of this particular work
and the darkness uh that it uh
that it sheds oh and on the matter of
time i was thinking because
i'm sorry to revert to an earlier
question because it uh i think
one of the things not just it takes time
to tell the story but stories build up
over time
so that what is the holocaust of course
is
is not known uh in 1944 1945
and it requires really decades of work
uh that is both scholarly and
testimonial in nature
for the various aspects and dimensions
of this thing
of this monstrosity uh to start to come
into focus for people
uh so in that sense this is also uh
this is another temporal dimension uh to
the
to the story i have to tell so uh we
have so many great
questions here and i'm i'm going to
apologize for not being able to ask all
of them and i'm just going to skip to
some things that we haven't touched on
but i think are really important so
there's a question from
sam moyn from our colleague about
what's at stake in uh focusing on
french writing french across the genres
versus for instance some of the early
writing in yiddish
um and speaking in yiddish about um
the deportation so uh two things
one is i don't do the use so that is it
that is an
obstacle i got help uh translating ellie
wiesel's
uh at night when it first was published
in uh in the edition i was interested in
the translation
uh from uh french india but second of
all
uh and and so this isn't just how i
don't have the skills uh
it's also i want it in the domain of
french public life uh and yiddish is not
the linguistic means by which that will
happen
uh it has to happen in french uh and so
that's why uh
the focus is on the french language uh
the french language corpus
uh it's not that i'm not interested it's
a quite
wonderful uh wonderful book by a young
man named simon perego whom
who uh you i don't know if you all know
him but i know carol carolyn
carol knows him uh which is about the
parisian
uh jewish world uh largely
or significantly yiddish speaking and
the way in which
uh the experience and memorialization
and mourning
of loss is present in a very powerful
way almost in a constitutive way
after world war after world war ii so
if you're interested in that there there
it is
and he does it beautifully but i want it
when the world when the world
beyond the borders of the jewish
community is made to pay attention
uh or is led to pay attention uh and so
i think
the medium for that to happen is in the
french language itself
so here's a question um from ron levy
about
um how the memory of the deportation
intersects with other memories for
instance
of algeria um and the algerian war
so that that's a great question
uh so this is michael rothberg has
written
extensively and inventively
imaginatively
about this what i would have to add to
it
is that some of it depends on what your
politics are
and so for the non-communist left the
experience of the algerian war is
a wake-up call uh they are galvanized by
this
uh ex deportees uh
i mean something like charlotte dalbo is
a good uh as a good case in point
uh she was once a party member she she
leaves the party
uh she's ferociously anti-colonial and
she sees it through the experience
uh through the lens of her own
deportation experience to auschwitz
and it fuels her passion now there are
other people
uh like jeremiah who who
has been pantheonized uh for whom the
algerian war
is also a crushing experience uh
and she wants to find a solution to it
and she sees the war
and torture uh through the lens of her
own experience but she doesn't come out
for an independent algeria at the far at
the far end
so in both cases the war plays
an important role in mobilizing
and mobilizing them and their war
experience
shapes how they're mobilized but they
come out at slightly different
places uh just because you intersect
uh doesn't mean uh that you're gonna
come out
with the same view of the algerian war
some of that depends on your politics
uh and balboa is non-communist leftist
very
very left-wing uh and german tion is a
gallus
uh and so they come out uh both shaped
uh
by the algerian war and the connection
or intersectionality
that's not the word multi-directionality
that's his work
uh between these two experiences but
they come out of different places
because they enter them politically
differently great so here's a
question from my colleague in the french
department howard block um if you could
say
more about the public places of memory
not the great ones but those small signs
on lysse and in public gardens um and
especially i've noticed
also that they've changed in in recent
years and now well anyway i'll let you
know i actually i would be interested in
how they how they've changed
i mean i've noticed that um on schools
for instance they're much
more it seems like it's a change that
they're much more willing to say that
it was jewish children to mention the
jewishness
of the children who were deported
whereas i feel like when i used to go to
france like in the first times in the
80s i don't remember
that but i could be wrong so no i and i
don't of course you know it's one of
those things when you when do you start
looking
and paying attention uh and uh so my
experience is like yours uh
like yours morning no i think in
response to the question
it's a it's a it's a critique that to
say i don't do it
uh i look at the oh yeah as a you know
the high places
um now
what could i say i could have an
impression which is one that
these local memorials are a more recent
phenomenon
but i don't know that for a fact it's
what i suspect
but i don't know because i didn't i
didn't study it
uh the mentioning of jews a good case is
easier it's not a local
well it's local it's now a major
national memorial too
it had right away this is the jewish
home in the
uh not far from the french alps a jewish
home for children and it had a memorial
early on
uh but it said nothing about who the
children were now they did have a mug
and david on it
uh but no mention no precision after
that
and this changes in the 1990s completely
and it's identified
both the both the home itself and the
plaque that's on the home
and the monument which is located some
distance away where they talk about
who the killers were who the the
people who saved children and who the
children were who died that they were
jewish children
and so i think that and a good perfect
i'll give you another good
it's not exactly a local i'm sorry i'm
dodging the question but this is more in
line with what you said maurice
there's an auschwitz memorial paralyzed
cemetery was erected by
by communists in 1995 the plaque that
you see
is added there that identifies the
people who died at auschwitz as being
principally jews
that's only added in the mid 19th 1990s
so i have a feeling that this sort of
local story and the local story where
jews are identified by name
uh is a last 30-year story
a little bit after or where i wind where
i wind down
so here's a really interesting question
about the role of the
organized jewish community in france
uh in controlling memories so like the
consistent
did they try to limit the importance
of the jewish component of the
deportation
out of fear that it would arouse
anti-semitism
or that they'd be accused of
communitarism and things like that
uh this is this is it's an interesting
i'll tell you what i have on that uh
which is the consistent
early uh puts up a plaque uh in the
rutala victoire synagogue
uh it's in the peristyle there which
talks about
all who were lost but it's actually very
reticent
about identifying the people who died as
jews now it's innocent but it's in the
synagogue
at the same uh at the same time so it's
a little bit hidden away and when isaac
schneerson
and the santo de documentary
wants to build the monument the
consistent is reluctant and schneerson
has to go it
has to go alone he's very creative very
dynamic
dynamically so there's some reticence
about that but
not not completely because the costly
stoir does get ashes
uh or soil from concentration camps and
distributes them around france for
memorial purposes
it has history services it has memorial
uh memorial services
so while they're low-key and not
insistent
they're not in denial and uh it's an
interesting phenomenon france has
something called the
journey nacional deportacion every april
a deportation memorial day
and there's an itinerary uh
various stops along the way uh it was a
very
smallish affair when it began in 1954
but by 1955-56
uh the rudolphi dwarf synagogue figured
as part of this
as well as notre dame as well as
schneerson's memorial
uh as well as a number of other
memorials as well and so even at this
early stage uh in the mid 50s we are you
have the jewish story
with the cosistoire included
part of the general itinerary
for memorialization of the deportation
so um we're almost out of time but there
are two other questions
i want to make sure to get to so one uh
is and this is a big question but
um so try to answer it you know quickly
if you can but
what will the large immigration of north
african jews
uh plays in your story so you know the
fact that you know hundreds of thousands
of
jews come because of decolonization and
are now the
um you know the the biggest segment of
the french jewish population
i don't know if you remember our
exchange carol and maury
i i got taken the task for these things
and that one too and so i
i have a feeling we've got another sharp
audience on our hands here
um you know i really focus and it's a
blind spot i
fear it is i mean i it's i focus on the
ashkenazi community
uh into the into the 1960s and the way
in which it's
it's very much transformed by the
arrival of north african jews there
doesn't figure in my story and maybe it
should
uh and then it's something that i've uh
that i've missed it inflects the story
or shapes it
or rewrites it in surprising uh in
surprising way
i i need to be persuaded
is the way i would put it um i i'm i
don't want to be skeptical
uh but it may be more like uh
i should be careful when i say uh the
way in which the civil war
uh in the united states is part of my
memory
but i wasn't here nor were any of my
ancestors when it happened
uh and i wondered if it's not the same
thing
for a smarty jew of course there are
some i mean
one of schneerson's right hand man that
meant is vidal modiano
uh and i write about modiano's uh um
not vidal but the the novelist
modiano's work and they have svardi
background
as well but they're part of the story
and i don't know that they have
bring a distinctive something i i wonder
if you could argue that they
liberated a certain way of being jewish
in france and that
that enabled the ashkenazis to be more
i don't see i bet i did i don't buy
because the ashkenazi schneerson
he doesn't need anyone to liberals he's
he's a feisty character and uh you know
ready ready to
put up his nukes or even julie zach is a
good case appointment he's a
he's a classic uh native-born
uh jew who's not particularly interested
in his judaism
but an educator interested in republican
schooling
but the experience of the war where he
has to go into hiding
one of his children is in the resistance
his wife and daughter are deported
and murdered another kid is deported and
comes back
and he is full of polemic
uh when and he's not holding back at all
and he doesn't need
uh an influx of anybody uh to help him
decide
uh to stand up for what he what he sees
needs standing up for
and this in the late 1940s so it's not
as though
and he's writing jesus this is apropos
of timing once again
he's writing it starting under the
occupation
while his family is being murdered not
completing it after the war
publishing it and then going toe-to-toe
with catholic clerics for years on end
uh and in fact it's he's the one well
i'm doing this
uh who talks to uh to john the 23rd
and says when vatican 2 happens you have
to put this
on the dock and the pope says you know
what i'm going to do that
uh and he did it that's how it got there
uh
so uh i don't think it liberates the new
i mean
it does yes and it but
i think that's not part of my story
necessarily okay i'm
i'm noticing you know great questions
from uh richard weisberg from katie
trumpner i'm going to make sure you see
all these questions but i
want to ask because we're out of time
but i want to ask a last question
briefly like how the book has been
received in france
and is it going to be translated into
french that was a question from the
audience uh
yeah so i hope so uh uh annette beckhair
is trying to find a
publisher for me uh i i suspect i've
been published before and so actually
that's a plus or minus right
if i don't sell uh no there's no reason
no reason to
you know another another dud from me uh
um but there was more seriousness to the
question than that yeah about the
reception in france oh um
well you know it's all been my friends
so far uh
and uh you know they like the book uh
you know what friends or uh friends are
like um
so um i'm hopeful
but i don't know i don't know just yet
how it'll be
okay well we'll see we can uh you know
we'll we'll look forward to
to um to hearing about it but i do uh
encourage everyone to check out the
review and especially to read the book
um it's just
it's not only just a fascinating book
but it's actually just a beautifully
written book and a really good read
so um i i recommend it to everyone
very highly so please join me in
silently
thanking uh phil nord for this really
enlightening
um afternoon presentation we're really
really grateful to you so thank you
thank you all thank you for coming i
appreciate it i really do
maury carolyn thank you yeah and please
uh make sure if you're not
um signed up for the yale program for
the study of anti-semitism uh that you
go to our website and um put your name
on the list
and then you'll hear about our other
great activities we have a couple more
lectures this semester and we look
forward to seeing you there so thank you
all very much